are you uh excited for your first day of
school my dad
oh it's not a prison can I leave
whenever I want to
I want it's a little like a prison
where'd you go to school before this I
didn't my dad and I
lived in a lighthouse
but now he's gone
I want to show you something
that's my dad back then he told me
stories every night about wild
adventures we were gonna go on and get
out
sweet dreams
[Music]
a pig what
[Applause]
how is this possible
[Music]
land the world of Dreams
your dad and our partners a long time
ago your flip he told stories about you
every night all right going on a little
treasure hunt this treasure lets you let
you whatever you want
I could see my dad again
are you going through this door
Everything Changes okay
what are we waiting for that's the
spirit
[Applause]
rule number one stay focused you slip up
we'll never see the waking world again
for one or two keep a little profile
we're not here to have fun
no dream lasts forever sooner or later
it's time to wake up
I don't want to wake up
I just want to see my dad again
is waiting for you Nemo you can do
anything you dream
[Applause]
you said we weren't here to have fun I
said you're not here to have fun
if I'm not having fun I'm doing my job
wrong
[Music]